-Welcome.
-This is such a fun show, Seth.
I'm digging it.
-I am so happy to have you here
because obviously
you have a very fast turnaround.
You have to be both on TV now
when people are going to bed.
And then first thing in the
morning,
they're going to see you
as well.
-Exactly, I got
a quick turnaround.
-And your morning got earlier.
You're now doing
the first two hours,
or in other words 7:00 to 9:00.
-Yeah.
-And then you have an hour off.
That's 7:00 to 9:00 with
Savannah on the "Today" show
and then you're back at 10:00
with Kathie Lee.
-You got it.
-And did you ever consider
not doing the Kathie Lee part
anymore
once you did the 7:00 to 9:00?
-I like -- I like that 10:00.
-I like the 10:00 too.
-You know what it is?
It's laughing
and scratching and drinking.
It's like not --
It's not heavy lifting.
It's a fun little hour, yeah.
-You know, by the time
we all get in,
the "Today" show that's on TV
is the 10:00 "Today" show.
And I think we all look at it
lovingly wondering
why we work at a comedy show
and we're having less fun
than you guys.
[ Laughter ]
-By the way, we started pouring
wine on that show,
and I promise you, I felt like
the suits had no clue.
And one day, they just watched
our show and said,
"How long has that
been going on?"
I know, it was the best.
-How did it start?
Whose idea was it
to start having wine?
-Okay, you know what happened?
Chelsea Handler came on
and she had that book,
"Hello Vodka, It's Me Chelsea."
-I love -- By the way, I'm not
surprised Chelsea enabled this.
-Okay, so she -- so we served
her some drinks.
And then Brooke Shields showed
up the next day
and she was like,
"Where's mine?"
And we go, "Where's your what?"
She goes, "Where's my booze?"
And we're like,
"Get her some booze,"
and then, all of the sudden,
it just happened.
-Yeah.
[ Laughter ]
-And I think --
I thought you were --
I thought it was illegal
to drink on the air.
I thought there was
some FCC violation.
But apparently no.
-Yeah.
And -- and --
[ Laughter ]
I -- Are you -- I feel like you
guys should be, if you're not,
you should be beloved by
the wine industry.
I hope you are.
-I think we are.
You know, Kathie Lee's got
a line of wine.
-Yeah.
-And we do our --
our share of hocking it.
-Okay, good.
[ Laughter ]
-You were in South Korea
for the Olympics.
How was that?
-Can I tell you,
it was an absolute ball.
-Yeah.
-We got to go to
a ton of the events.
We were --
Do you guys remember when
the U.S. women's hockey team won
in that, like, nail-biter?
-Shoot-out. Yeah.
-It was crazy.
[ Cheers and applause ]
It was -- We went to that game.
Roker and I were freaking out.
It was U.S. versus Canada.
It went down to the shoot-out.
It was one of my favorite
moments I think at the Olympics.
-It was great,
and then, someone --
A Canadian guy posted
a wonderful video.
He was obviously aware
that you guys were behind him.
And during the shoot-out,
he shot himself reacting to
Canada losing
while you guys were celebrating
behind him.
I thought he was
a very good sport.
Let's take a look at this fine
Canadian gentleman.
-USA! USA!
[ Laughter ]
-He was totally --
[ Cheers and applause ]
-But you --
You guys tracked him down
and you had him on the show.
-Do you know what was funny?
One of our producers saw him
on Insta and they said,
"We got to get this guy in."
And he came in at midnight Korea
time and was on the air with us.
He was a great sport.
-That's fantastic.
-He was a great sport, yeah.
-I would imagine, you know, I've
been to -- I've never been to --
No, I guess I have been
to a Winter --
I went to Vancouver
and I went to London.
It is that spirit of everybody
just collectively
being in a great mood.
Did you go to any of the --
I heard you went to half pipe.
Is that --
-I went to see Shaun White
after he nailed it.
He was unbelievable.
And Chloe Kim, those two.
Watching those guys just fly
through the air, it's just --
It's like, if you could do one
thing in your life
and feel that free.
-Yeah.
-Yeah. It was the best.
Watching Shaun win
was something.
-I cry all the time
watching the Olympics.
Do you -- When you're actually
there working,
do you find yourself as
emotionally attached to it
as somebody like me who's
sitting at home like a dummy?
Because you're not --
I have to hear all
the NBC music and, like,
you guys are pulling my heart
strings the whole time.
-Can I -- There is something
about a kid
whose name you don't know
before you walk in.
And you watch their parents who
are standing right next to them.
They've driven them to the rink
at 4:00 in the morning,
they've practiced forever,
and it comes down to,
like, this one minute.
And you're watching this kid's
life change,
like, in front of your eyes.
I am such a crybaby
at the Olympics
because I feel everything.
-Yeah. My wife walked in on me
watching the Olympics and crying
and just like said, "Wha-haa,"
and went to bed.
[ Laughter ]
She's like,
"I can't do this again."
[ Laughter ]
But you have a 1-year-old.
And you were away for her
for an Olympics,
which is no small amount
of time.
And how was it? Was it hard? How
did you communicate with her?
-We did -- we did a bunch of
Facetime.
-Here is your beautiful
daughter, by the way.
I want to show a picture
while we're talking.
There she is.
-That's Joel.
-That's Joel and your daughter.
So how did you talk to her?
-So, we did it on Facetime.
And I was hoping she wouldn't
hit any milestones
while I was gone because that
makes you feel kind of crummy.
But my mom was with her,
and my mom kept telling her
to say mama.
Say mama.
So she videotaped
Haley saying mama.
So, I was playing it
and I was so excited.
And I got home
and I was like, "Hey!"
Like, "It's me."
And she pointed to my phone
and she was like, "Mama! "Mama!"
I'm like, "No, no!"
Oh, my God.
The phone is mama.
That is horrifying.
-You look like my mama who lives
in this phone.
[ Laughter ]
So you and your boyfriend Joel,
you guys live together.
And, obviously, you are an adult
and that is
a totally normal thing.
But is it true that you were
nervous to tell your mom
that you were going to move in
with your boyfriend?
-That's so weird. I know.
I'm 51 year-- 52 years old when
I moved in with Joel,
which all sounds so crazy.
And I remember getting kind of
a little pit in my stomach
to tell my mom.
I know it sounds nuts,
but don't you always feel
like a kid around your mom?
-Yes.
-I'm like,
"Mom, he's a great guy."
"We're going to move in
together."
She was like,
"Oh, and no marriage? Okay."
[ Laughter ]
"Okay. I guess that's good
for you."
But I know.
A grown-- I was terrified.
But keep in mind.
We moved in, in December.
And Haley came, you know,
in February.
So everything changed in,
like, an instant.
-Yeah, that is definitely --
He might've thought he was
moving in with a nice lady,
and then, he was like,
"Whoa, this whole thing is
a lot more than I thought."
-I think he kind of freaked out.
[ Laughter ]
-Well, he can call his mom
and tell her all about it.